[Music]
hey guys welcome to UT live we are here
back with the champ Chris blue live is
here thank you thank you voice winner
last season reigning voice champ for now
until the show kicks off again next week
so let's talk about what you been up to
the last time I saw you we were right
here on Facebook live it was the morning
after your big win oh my gosh such an
incredible credible memory I have so a
lots been going on a lots changed so you
remember that fiance I had yeah so she's
no longer my fiancee she's your wife
she's my wife I got a shout-out I was
looking at your ring earlier you've got
some bling in there yeah so she she kind
of went all out
hooked me up a little bit a lots changed
I married my coach Alicia Keys she's not
only my coach anymore but she's now my
manager
she's our manager yeah stop sign to
Alicia and the team so Alicia Johnny
right hollering hill all those guys
managing me right now a great team
around me and I have a record deal with
Republic that's been going on a lot of
great things I love it well let's dive
into the new music I saw on Instagram
Alicia has been showing you some love on
Instagram that's awesome
in addition to being your manager are
you guys working together in the actual
studio it looks like you are yeah yeah
absolutely we've um we've had a couple
songs we've been working on quite a few
she's been on like she's had her hand in
everything really yeah so she's been a
part of every song in fact I probably go
back in work with her on a couple more
coming up pretty soon probably the next
couple of weeks when you say she's got a
hand in every track kind of explained to
me what that means is she producing is
she singing with you is she writing with
you what's she doing man um probably all
all of the above
yeah she's got her hand in everything
she's writing we're writing together
she's producing I'm trying to get her on
a track we'll see what happens yeah but
you know I won't complain I she's
producing she's writing I'm good with
that
I'm good with that that's amazing so
then I mean
learning experience continues I feel
she's really the first coach who's
gotten that involved
yeah with a contestant which is
incredible oh yeah yeah yeah you know I
can't remember you know like you know
recent history you know some of the
coaches experienced post-show but from
what I can remember you know she's been
kind of like the first to step out and
really you know believe in the artist
and say you know what I'm gonna put my
name on this I'm gonna stamp it and um
it's been a lot to me and I'm just a
minim blessed man I'm humbled I'm
grateful for it too
so when can we expect to hear some of
the stuff you've been working on well if
you follow me on all my social platforms
I'm starting to put up a few sneak peeks
on Instagram Krispy live Facebook crispy
live Twitter Chris blue live plug it so
if you know you follow me comes on the
fam you know you'll catch a few sneak
peeks but it's coming soon we're working
hard though like every single day in the
studio and just you know just crying and
skating is it a conscious effort to get
stuff out as quickly as possible to kind
of capitalize on because it's been how
long since you won um oh gosh a little
over 90 days really oh my gosh let's see
I mean so much has happened in those 90
days okay so I mean you're working
you're grinding it out you're really
working hard working really is that a
conscious decision like you're just
trying to get out quick with it you know
at first it was I was like you know you
got to strike when the iron's hot yeah
yeah but for me what's most important is
just being transparent and just giving
my heart you know and my prayers that
you know people will continue to love me
whether they wait for a month or three
months you know just if people love you
they love you so I hope y'all keep
loving me because I love y'all feeling
loved let's talk about your love your
wife tell me about the wedding how was
it come on it was incredible
um I didn't do any work except show up
late you were late I was late I was I
was late from wrong with it it was crazy
were you later than your wife yeah I was
an hour early stop then it meant she was
okay so I decided you know when I got to
London I want to drive so I started
driving you know and they drive them
like the opposite side of the road yeah
and at nighttime you know you know it's
it's a bit harder you know and I parked
in a bus lane and I woke up and my car
was gone
oh no they towed the car man can't you
get a taxi about well
it wasn't my car was her dad's car so
early just off to a great start
yeah I didn't have a choice I had to get
the car out or else yeah gone down well
you you made it there you got married
your wife's from London right yeah yeah
yeah so where are you guys based now
well right now we're still in Tennessee
but we're not even in Tennessee to be
honest with you because I've been moving
so much yeah I don't know how long we'll
be there she really loves Los Angeles
she's here with me now I had to bring
her cuz she was like there's no way
you're going without me so she's are you
hanging out with me who knows we may be
in LA you know I was gonna ask if your
wife goes out on the road with you if
she's along for the journey and I may be
biased here but I would love to have you
in LA oh my god join the fun out here my
gosh listen I'm trying my best to remain
a southern boy but I'm being pulled out
with and I feel the energy you guys are
like grabbing me and like oh just stop
it
I want to stay a southerner I'm
surprised Alicia's not trying to get you
up in New York well I really like New
York yeah I really love New York you
know when I first got to New York I
didn't think I would like it but it
feels like home and you know you guys
got some competition I feel you I like
LA better but I'm biased it's usually
nice weather today's rainy but yeah we
don't usually get rain this is an
unusual circumstance for ya
so let's get to some fan questions you
guys are sending on keep on coming you
guys we're getting them right here on
this tablet so Anna wants to know when
does the song with Alicia come out but I
know you're mean you're working with her
on all of them yeah absolutely
well again we're working on all the
songs together I don't know if we'll
have an Alicia Keys Chris duet
we'll see maybe maybe not no but it may
have
and so just you know stay tuned Edward
wants to know curious what your favorite
Alicia Keys song is funny it's crazy so
it's it's a tie
I'm queen if I ain't got you because
that's the first song I learned on piano
it's like really like the first and like
the only song I can really play home for
you
trying to impress a girl in high school
long story and you probably succeeded
right no she didn't know they didn't
work no I didn't work I know but it's
cool it's cool my other my other
favorite Alicia Keys song I would have
to go with you don't know my name it
puts me there every time so Kieran says
Chris you are already a legend that's a
song that is sweet thank you how has
your life changed since you won do you
have people recognizing you on the
street or anything like that
oh yeah you know restaurants from
walking down the street in the mall
I'm always stopped I've probably smiled
more in the last 90 days and I've ever
had in my life
behind takes I'm a selfie King now I
know how to take a selfie out of this
world
guys like people try to come up and take
selfies I'm like no I got you let me
just give me your phone are you guys all
right got it so here's a trick like you
gotta grab it okay and then [ __ ] it to
the side just slightly slanted
yes slanting just a little bit hit the
button on the side hit your volume down
button there you go okay you know what
my best friend actually takes all of her
photos diagonal that's like her
signature moves got to this so the voice
is kicking off next week what advice do
you have for the people going Oh first
of all before we get to that I got to
ask you about your hat you're totally
something I thought about that hat
before we got rolling yes this is like
my lucky hat everywhere I go people
recognize me when I wear this hat
yeah that's airports I mean anywhere you
can think of if I'm wearing this hat I'm
getting stopped never fails because it's
your audition hat right yeah this is a
hat I wore in my audition last season
that's amazing so you can't ever lose it
no this special no it's special
yeah well I'm so honored that you wore
it today I was coming to see you I had
to wear my logo
yes okay so let's talk about the
upcoming season of The Voice we've got
miley jennifer hudson like an atom yeah
what advice do you have for all the
people who are auditioning and and what
what's the the secret sauce to winning
what's your secret to success well if I
told you it wouldn't be a secret anyone
else so the advice I would give would
simply be to relax okay
enjoy it you know have fun
don't don't overthink don't overanalyze
be present be in the moment everything
else will fall into place and take care
of itself
I overthought everything did you yeah I
did I was a nervous wreck oh my gosh
does that make it miserable for you
though when you're just constantly
stressed out because you can't enjoy the
moment yeah no this is something that
happens once in a lifetime and it's an
experience that you'll never forget so
be present be in the moment so good all
then enjoy it because once it's over
it's over
yeah all you have to live live with are
the memories that you have you know and
and and the experience that you've that
you share with the people there so do
you think like what is the strongest
memory to you from that experience
called Mike gold Michael
strongest memory I would say was the
audition man really that's what stands
out that's a sense yeah that stood out
it's a few of them stand the audition
Rhythm Nation the performance you know
that was like in saying it and we didn't
have a lot of time to put that together
but you know Jerry and Paul and the guys
and the dancers like we worked hard we
had every bit of about two hours to get
that together and it was it was crazy
stopping yeah but it was a lot of fun -
man there's a lot of fun Wow
that's down to the wire on that show I
don't think a lot of people realize how
much you guys are like scrambling at the
last minute to get your stuff ready oh
yeah her show especially when it's live
oh my god absolutely so you perform
Monday Tuesday are you eliminations and
then the following day you have to start
working on your next
yeah yeah so there's a lot of work that
goes into it no rest well I mean it must
have prepared you really well for the
speed of the industry and absolutely
absolutely it's a great great platform
to not only you know catapult you to the
next level in your career but it like
you said it enables you to brace
yourself for the impact of just the
craziness that's gonna hit you once it's
all over so no it was stellar yeah great
job went right for it you won The Voice
got married working on your album with
Alicia it's been non-stop Patricia says
congratulations to you and your wife on
your wedding thank you and getting a lot
of those Congrats huh yeah no I'm gonna
put you right on the spot do you see
yourself having kids see why you gotta
talk I'm newly married too so I know how
it is but I got it gosh I don't know I
don't think we're gonna have any little
Chris's running around anytime soon
you're busy I am I'm trying not to but
that may change you never know so back
to the voice we've got Jennifer and
Miley while Miley's done it before
Jennifer did it in the UK did you ever
watch Jennifer on the UK version of The
Voice I did I caught a few because you
know again you know my wife's right so I
would catch her watching it and I'm like
you know
Jennifer's pretty good at this you know
I wonder if she's gonna ever you know
transition over to the states and now
she's here yeah I mean it's it's still
the same but yet different so I'm
excited to see how she you know
approaches this this season this is
gonna be fun though i sat in on a couple
of the blind auditions and I thought she
has a thing where she throws her shoe
and she's really excited about something
have you seen that like in it to win it
Oh big time I'm loving it she's fierce
I've been telling people she's fierce
like watch out cuz her energy is gonna
be yeah so who do you think is gonna
take it this season Alicia's out of the
running this season obviously so you
don't have any bias there right right I
don't know man
who wants it the most I'm gonna go with
either my own I'm gonna go with Maile or
Blake but my guts telling me Adam for
some reason really I don't know I think
Adams gonna win this season I think
Adams hungry for it it's been a while
yeah
and Blake gives them a hard time oh yeah
they give each other our time that's
pretty funny yeah yeah well thank you so
much for being here Chris you guys stay
tuned to his social media for all the
latest updates right yeah yeah it's
gonna be great man that's crispy live on
Facebook Chris B live on Instagram and
Chris blue live on Twitter why Chris
blue live on Twitter because Chris B
live was already taken so I couldn't you
gotta fight for that I tried man like my
arms are too short I couldn't box to get
it that's all right I know I wish you
had your wrestling belt with you today
where's that now I left it at home it's
in a case now it's in a case oh yes
[ __ ] up amazing so hopefully uh this
McMahon and the WrestleMania team will
invite me out because that's one of my
dreams beyond WrestleMania someday oh my
gosh 11th hour great question that just
came in have you ever thought of
becoming a judge or a coach is the
correct term have you ever thought about
becoming a coach on the voice oh wow
that would be interesting um be pretty
cool I never thought about it but you
know what if the opportunity ever
presented itself we may have to jump
into it yeah cuz that's like I don't
think anyone's ever done that before no
I don't think anybody i mean they've had
winners come back and perform on the
show right i don't know if they've had
anyone mentor or anything like that i
can't remember
so that that'd be pretty cool I'd love
to do that it'd be really cool have you
been in talks with anybody about about
making an appearance this season I don't
know you don't know maybe I have that
sounds like a yes to me you guys gotta
stay tuned watch the show watch the show
it's coming back Monday thank you so
much for joining us I'm gonna give you a
shameless plug for myself I am at sofa
Chalet see on Twitter and Instagram so
you can follow both of us we're gonna be
posting some selfies there later today
yeah yeah yeah let's get it thank you
guys for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]